-Good evening, everybody.
I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well.
And now, if you don't mind,
we're gonna get to the news.
Today is the Georgia
Senate runoff,
and there's only one candidate
in the race
who definitely knows that.
[ Laughter ]
Georgia Republican Senate
candidate Herschel Walker said
during a rally over the weekend
that he doesn't know
what a pronoun is.
And someone said, "It's what you
call your illegitimate kids."
And he said, "Oh, them?"
[ Laughter ]
That's right, Herschel Walker
said at a rally over the weekend
that he doesn't know
what a pronoun is.
Okay, it cannot be good for
Raphael Warnock's self-esteem
that this is a close race.
I mean, imagine
seeing your opponent
basically eating paste
on TV every night
and knowing he might win.
[ Laughter ]
When asked yesterday about
former President Trump
calling for the termination
of the Constitution,
Nebraska Senator Ben Sasse
asked if Republicans
"want to keep giving oxygen to
someone who is trying to sell
tickets to his own
proprietary circus,
or do they want to be
a constitutional party."
Said Republicans,
"We're thinking."
[ Laughter ]
President Biden today toured
a semiconductor
manufacturing company
in Phoenix, Arizona,
and honestly, I don't even know
if he did that because
he's the president
or just because he's 80
and it's Tuesday.
"Come on, kids!
Come on.
It'll be interesting.
My friend Frank works
over at the semiconductor place.
He's gonna give us
a look at it.
You have no idea!
You use semiconductors
every day!"
[ Laughter ]
-In a new interview,
Eric Trump pushed back
against reports that
the Trump family doesn't like
Don Jr.'s fiancée,
Kimberly Guilfoyle.
Okay, but keep in mind,
he also thinks they like him.
[ Laughter ]
Indonesia's Parliament today
outlawed premarital sex.
What?
But that's the good kind.
[ Laughter ]
Eh...
-A middle school nurse
in Florida was accused last week
of taking more than 100
Adderall pills
from at least five children
and replacing them with aspirin.
And she had the right
to remain silent,
but that's not an option
after 100 Adderall.
"Okay, I wasn't supposed
to do that, but also,
maybe it's okay because that
means someone down the road
will know not to do it,
so that's actually
for the greater good
when you think about it.
And you know what else?
I should totally write
a novel about this!"
[ Laughter and applause ]
Thank you. [ Chuckles ]
[ Applause continues ]
And that was Adderall Theater.
[ Laughter ]
It was recently announced that
the Ripley's Believe It or Not!
Museum in Atlantic City
will close at the end
of the year,
because when you walk
around Atlantic City,
anything becomes believable.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, a charity
in Australia recently attempted
to break a Guinness World Record
by lining up nearly 1,100
wrapped presents.
It would beat the previous
record holder --
someone whose parents
just got divorced.
[ Laughter and groans ]
-And that's a Merry Christmas
monologue joke
from the monster Mike Scollins.
That was a monologue, everybody.
We're off and running!